foreign
you know that we've all done stupid with
money around here Jade and I included
and sometimes it's fun to laugh about it
and the important thing is we don't make
that mistake again we grow we move on
that's right but uh there's this Yahoo
article Jade that I thought was kind of
hilarious kind of sad 17 things people
spent big money on that they're kicking
themselves over looking back so I wanted
to cover a few and get your takes yes
let's do it let's do it all right this
one was an interesting one someone said
a timeshare oh well we already know
about that okay so this guy said I went
to the seminar for a three-night stay at
a beach resort and they got me they were
phenomenal salesmen but they lie out of
their beeps we spent thousands over
years only use the timeshare once we
hear that all the time George they only
use it look they almost got me one time
in Las Vegas dang I didn't know that's
what it was and I ended up on this bus
getting ready to go to wherever the
times
yeah and then when I tried to get off
the bus they would not let me off the
bus George so I know how I'm not getting
in Jade's way that's a bold move I had
to get medieval on him so yeah this
person goes on to say they paid a lawyer
to get them out of the contract uh now
they're free these things are scams and
if you don't believe me uh how terrible
of an investment they are which by the
way you don't own anything so not really
invested in anything you can find them
on eBay for a dollar people are
desperately trying to get rid of them
well he's fortunate that he was able to
get out of his because it ain't easy let
me tell you all right here's another one
someone said I bought a mobile home as a
starter home no one ever explained to me
as a young adult the importance of
investment in future planning mobile
homes of course do not hold nor increase
in value so you never build equity it's
akin to renting except you have to cover
all of your own repair costs too it's a
terrible financial decision do not buy
mobile homes kids just don't do it good
advice there yeah it's going down in
value
let's see I see this one down here this
is about credit cards George this is you
are my favorite favorite topic he says I
opened a credit card in college bought
something I don't even remember what it
was and completely forgot about it I
never got a statement and three years
later I suddenly have collections
agencies calling me non-stop over a
twenty dollar debt with hundreds of
collection fees it took me years to get
my credit back to not crappy levels wow
been there been there and we did it all
for the free t-shirt back in college
been there done that on the college how
is it even legal to let these people on
the college campus I don't know dude
gosh I we've all done it now here's one
I I have never done this is an
interesting one someone said I agreed to
take over my ex-girlfriend's bills so
that she could pay off her debts five
years and over a hundred thousand
dollars of my money later she was in
more debt than when we started and
cheating on me don't ever do this just
make her be an adult or a dumper it's
never are worth it this is like this
needs to go on Mori or something yeah
yeah they need to be on um that is some
drama
oh that's terrible my ex-girlfriends I
can't think of one ex-girlfriend that I
want to give a dollar let alone cover
all of her bills you know what people
will do anything love is blind I think
when he was paying the bills they were
dating they were I think you're right I
think they were dating and then it came
back to bite him in the butt because
she's cheating on him after he's giving
them six figures don't guys you don't
yes whine and dine your ladies but do
not pay their debts do not don't do it
don't co-sign please yikes that was a
name right there she she took advantage
of that homie yeah I don't dig that let
me let me let me read this one this one
she says uh financing a car and then
leasing a new one so she financed the
used car leased a new one never again I
bought my current car in a new light
condition and paid it in full with cash
I love never having to deal with I am
with it I love never having to deal with
car payments that's great once you get
fleeced you ain't never going back can I
tell you all a secret do you know that
when I was dating Sam he this this goes
along with this dumpster stuff he bought
my used car we were we were engaged
but I had a car and he thought that I
should have a better car and he bought
me a Jeep Liberty and luckily when once
we got married we hoped snowball it
together these are bad choices people
what a romantic Samus I'm saying this to
say this is the dumb stuff we do nothing
says love like a financial transaction
like co-signing yeah right this one got
me someone said lending my credit card
to family
how few brain cells you need to have to
trust your family with a credit card
it's like giving a kid just Monopoly
money
to go spend George I'm scared I'm scared
can I okay we gotta share our stupid
ones all right what's yours okay can I
tell you guys this is the dumbest thing
I've ever done because it was just extra
dumb I went to college George I had two
full score I had a full presidential
scholarship which means everything paid
for and I had a full volleyball athletic
scholarship wow my bills were paid for
college and do you know that the
financial aid folks talked me into
taking out
student loans so that I could pay for
just life they said Jade you're going to
need new clothes you're going to want
after the games you're going to want to
go out to eat with your friends and I
took out student loans are they still
getting the kickback for this this is
insane thousand dollars George
that's what I did lived it up in college
I don't remember it I remember going to
Walmart spending 60 on groceries just
like everybody else I don't know what
happened to the money that's nuts beat
that uh well I once shipped a pair of
Air Force Ones on Craigslist to a guy in
Nigeria because he said it was for his
cousin
and I S and this was not like a Nigerian
prince thing I listed my Air Force Ones
for sale a nice pair of shoes and I got
an email from a guy who seemed legit he
was like Hey I want to get this as a
gift to my cousin he lives in Nigeria
I'll pay you extra for shipping leave
you an extra 50 bucks and I was like
sweet and he was like hey I'll Pay Pal
you right now I got the email from
PayPal what that showed the transaction
I went great I'm gonna go ship these
today
I went back a day later
the email from PayPal was not an email
from PayPal it was oh a forgery and I
clicked through the email address and
saw that it was all a lie the money
never actually hit my PayPal account and
these shoes were gone in Nigeria so this
is like a Nigerian homeboy this is like
a Nigerian cousin and I felt I fell for
it now here's the crazy part the shoes
showed up six months later back at my
door and it said Return to Sender what
so whoever was running the scam it must
have been a bad address or I don't know
I don't know George that's hilarious Air
Force ones I love it here's a crazy one
though that we didn't hit uh someone
said not mine but my dad's he bought 500
worth of collectible Star Trek dinner
plates in the 80s thinking they'd be
worth a ton of money in a few years oh
my gosh I feel like someone else
someone out there who's a big Star Trek
fan with some money they might be
willing to buy that I I might notice
some people I might know some people
who's willing to buy it not me
wow wow well here's the deal uh we've
all done stupid with money and we want
to hear your stories uh from our
listeners and so if you have a stupid
tax story where you made a financial
mistake you had some regrets and you're
okay with us laughing about it please
email us at ask ramseysolutions.com and
in the subject line put stupid tax ask
ramseysolutions.com subject line stupid
tax we'd love to hear it because I think
you know what it does it creates
some levity around money it makes it
more comfortable to admit our own
mistakes and everyone thinks they're
they've done the stupidest thing with
money and then you read another story
and you go nope yeah George everybody
has done something stupid with money
it's the people who refuse to admit it
that's still broke oh it's the people
who refused it because if you can't
admit it that means you haven't learned
and if you refuse to change
that even better you do stupid over and
over again that's a choice yeah yeah you
got to start learning from these
mistakes
ouch so here's the good news I stopped
doing stupid when I saw through this
broken system that was meant to keep me
broke I went through Financial Peace
University you did this as well this was
like 10 years ago now and I became so
much more aware of my money how other
people were trying to get my money what
I could be doing with my money and it
gave me such peace and confidence
because I realized oh I don't have to be
the smartest guy in the room I just have
to do a budget and stay out of debt
that's so true it's the simple things
George it's you know I think money
culture tries to make us think it's so
complex and it's only for the wealthy
it's only for certain people yeah then
there's the dude Bros but it's those
simple things living on less than you
make
getting on a budget can you believe it
paying off your debt who knew easy easy
can be hard but it don't have to be
smart to do smart stuff with money and
that's very encouraging for people like
me